[Music]
so
it is 6 30 in the morning
my flight is in like almost exactly
like four hours um
i am finishing up just like the very
last
parts of my cleaning out of my apartment
so i can you know move and not get fined
and whatnot um i'm very tired i'm very
tired i've been up
since 4 30 in the morning so it's been a
hot
minute up but at least i feel awake now
because
i woke up trying to change my flight i
was so tired i was so tired
um it's like let me show you what
this all looks like it's nothing there's
nothing here this is
the living room space
the kitchen is still messy
so i need to fix that
some of the furniture i am leaving
behind because it's actually not mine i
sub least subleased subletted
this place from somebody is just kind
enough to
leave behind her items and so um
over the next few days she's going to
deal with removing it
and everything but for the most part
it's pretty empty and so yeah let me
finish up the packing and get
going
[Music]
so i finally made it to my apartment oh
my gosh
that was a journey i i had
three so i had three bags like two
check-ins
a um carry-on and a purse
and oh my goodness doing that by
yourself is just not a good time luckily
they're all the
like four woolly like all-wheel drive
type first suitcases um and so it made
carrying like two in one hand a lot
better
but it definitely still was felt by
you know the arms and the back um
but yeah it was a smooth flight and took
a lift right here
i'm not the biggest fan of lax's um
like process of getting a lift it's very
like you have to take the shuttle to
like this area it's not just
you leave the airport and boom you can
just catch a ride maybe it is maybe i
did the wrong thing i don't know
but um yes i took a lift right here
my lyft driver was hilarious
he started talking about like how
everyone
like in the lake can be claimed to be
things they're not
and so he was like oh like the amount of
producers
that you will meet here when really
they're not producing anything just
babies it was the funniest
it was the funniest thing to me and so
that really gave me
the energy and um attitude i needed to
get my keys and you know bring the
suitcases up here look them up here
and now i am in my apartment so
let me give you a tour
so this is the front door and so
i'm going to walk over there but this is
the front door
so if we turn around
this is what we see when we walk
in on the left is the kitchen area
and then on the right is
the bathroom and so we'll start
by going in there
it's a perfectly fine bathroom the only
problem with
for me is that you don't
get a ton of light
despite what this video may say to you
it's quite dark actually in here
i like this that they have like a whole
rack i appreciate that very much
the fridge i've never seen fridge
handles
like this that are on this side
or like a fridge that's yeah faced
between
so that's gonna take a bit of getting
used
to
then here's the rest of the kitchen we
have
the european um
like washing machine the ones that wash
and dry
in the same machine
[Music]
so these drawers i like this
i like the very
large established
kitchen area
and so if you see it from the other side
this is what it looks like i like this a
lot
and so then to the right of the kitchen
is where i think i'm going to pudge like
my
desk and just office area
because it's just such a huge space and
i love that
but i'm going to go over here and show
you what the rest of the apartments just
like
it's 750 square feet
yeah i am a fan and i love
these windows
very large i'm interior facing as
you may be able to tell but i still get
a
like solid amount of sunshine so i do
appreciate that
yeah we have a nice island as a pole in
the middle
i think for like structural
concerns or something but
it's appreciated nonetheless
so this area would probably be my
bedroom
bed area maybe not bedroom
and then there's a closet
over here which is a really nice size
actually
there's no light on the inside
those are my suitcases because i just
got here
but there's no light inside i'll get
something to you know fix that
but what's shocking is there's no light
and yet
there's this well sir
how do i turn you on i i don't
understand
so i'm going to see about that i was
thinking about putting
a desk area here too for like a vanity
that way there's not two desks like out
in the open
[Music]
so there we have it it's really just a
huge open space
so there's not many nicks and crannies
that we need to see or check out
but just for one more look
here's that door the front door
and there we
have it
so it's definitely bigger than my last
place my last apartment
was about 510 510 square feet
so it's definitely bigger um so i do
appreciate that
and so yeah i'm just going to work on
how to furnish it i'm trying to get most
of my stuff
like facebook marketplace and you know
things like that
so that it's not too costly because oh
my gosh y'all
the apartment's not cheap it is not fun
having to shop for a rug that's
over a hundred dollars like but why
whole pillows being fifty dollars like
i don't understand i'm gonna try to get
some food now i have not eaten
at all other than cookies my mom made me
this morning
and so i'm very hungry so i'm gonna try
to get some food
and i'll check back with you all later
so i'm pretty much
done for the day i got some food found
this like little like
place right across the corner from me
but
uh i think i'm gonna have to go to
a property manager and fix up a few
things there's just a few things i
noticed
with the apartment that i would like
fixed
um just in any place i call home
really so hopefully that's good if
it's not you'll hear from me um
like you know just not having a great
time
but hopefully that's all good they're
all like pretty minor i
hope it's not gonna be a problem but
yeah thank you for watching this
move-in vlog if you hear an echo i
apologize i have
nothing in here other than this air
mattress that i'm pretty sure is leaking
um not even pretty sure it is it is
because every time i get
up it has shrunk about you know two
inches
so i might be waking up on the floor
to uh tomorrow but you know what only
positive thoughts only positive fives
and you all help
with that so thank you so much i
appreciate you
and i will see you all later bye